some daycare centers across the country
we're still using certain sleepers
blamed for dozens of infant deaths
despite a voluntary recall a nonprofit
advocacy group found that two types of
an inclined sleepers including the
fisher-price rock and play sleeper were
still in use we spoke to several parents
whose children died in Incline sleepers
our consumer investigative correspondent
Anna Werner is here with their message
and what families should look out for
Anna good morning this is what's called
an inclined sleeper this one a rockin
play made by fisher-price now the
company voluntarily recalled it in April
after reports of more than 30 infant
deaths other similar sleepers have also
been recalled some as recently as last
week now when recalls happen it means a
product should be taken off the shelves
and should not be used but many of these
still are being used now parents who
lost their babies want others to know
about the risks why are you here why did
you want to be here and do this I would
like to raise awareness there's people
out here that are still using the rock
and play sleeper that our children got
in Haley and Ty Hampton lost one of
their twin boys 13 week old Liam in
February he was a little baby a little
cold about you their little cuddle buddy
huh for Jonathan and Amanda Butler it
was their 10-week old daughter Aria in
January she was perfect
it was perfect I don't go a day without
thinking about her Casey Connolly's six
week old son Jamison twin two sister
Dorothy died in 2015 how often do you
think about him
oh I mean every time really there's no
all three families are suing
fisher-price
saying their babies died in a rock and
play incline sleeper the company and the
Consumer Product Safety Commission
announced a recall of around four point
seven million sleepers in April saying
since the products 2009 introduction
over 30 infant fatalities have occurred
in rock and play sleepers this is a
fundamentally dangerous product it
shouldn't be on the market pediatric
experts like
dr. Ben Hoffman say the device although
marketed as a sleeper was never safe for
infant sleep in part because of its
angle so the incline here is a huge
problem
first of all knowing what we know about
babies relatively large heads relatively
weak necks the upright positioning can
lead to the head flopping forward and
that can block the airway which is
devastating to babies and they can't
pick their heads back up correct
fisher-price told CBS News the loss of
any child is tragic and heartbreaking
safety is our highest priority another
company kids - also recalled some six
hundred ninety four thousand sleepers in
April after five infant deaths but a new
survey released by the US Public
Interest Research Group or PIRG has
found one out of ten surveyed daycares
nationwide still using recalled sleepers
from kids - and fisher-price US PIRG
Adam Garber what does it say about the
recall system in this country that you
were able to find these sleepers it says
that it's not working and if we're going
to keep children safe we have to make
sure that we can get these products out
quickly and efficiently
both fisher-price and kids - said in
statements they've taken multiple steps
to notify consumers about the recalls
Kids 2 says it sells to retailers and
consumers for single-family use only
fisher-price said it has reached out to
companies on the secondary market urging
them to take action to prevent unlawful
resales of its sleepers yet we found
numerous postings selling them on
Facebook Craigslist and eBay some from
parents who still seem to believe they
are safe that's why these parents told
us they're speaking out in an interview
for the first time if we could at least
help one family out of all the other
ones that are still using the rock and
play maybe that's what I'm here for
we don't want another baby to die
because of the rock and play is this
process working well enough to protect
these kids
I think it is I think it is Ann Marie
Buerkle is acting chairman of the
Consumer Product Safety Commission I
think in some cases and perhaps this one
it's it's been a frustrating a
frustrating path do you worry about the
sleepers that have been recalled that
are still out there I do worry there's a
lot of parents out there who may have
knowledge of the Ricoh but they love
that product and I would say to them
please don't use the product but the
parents we interviewed blame
fisher-price itself for some of the
confusion pointing to a statement the
company issued at the time of recall
saying that parents or caretakers used
the product contrary to the safety
warnings and instructions to hear that
statement from fisher-price
it's like it was like you know they gave
me this little something of taking these
death traps off the market and then took
it all the way now reports to the CPSC
do show that some infants did roll over
in those sleepers and were unrestrained
but all the parents we interviewed who
are suing fisher-price
say that was not the case with their
babies a fisher-price told us it does
not comment on litigation dr. Hoffman
with the American Academy of Pediatrics
says that these incline products however
are not safe for babies to sleep in
under any circumstances to sleep in what
is the proper way that an infant should
sleep this is such a critical time
they're so small and so little yeah and
that is so important on their back only
not on their side or on their stomach on
a firm surface in a crib or bassinet
that's approved with a fitted sheet and
nothing nothing around them no blanket
no toys no bumpers on the edges nothing
that's what doctors will tell you we
really want to thank those families yes
we know how hard that was yeah and I
understand their desire to have those
off the market completely on that second
market and I thank you